best and show winner is the French blue
oh David you're all right and look at
this
no one happier they have cornered the
market on energy enthusiasm and just
pure stuff
pure spunk indeed back in November
Winston the French Bulldog took on the
honors for Best in Show at the national
dog show in Philadelphia in a way
Winston's Victory heralded a new era for
these tiny dogs this week the American
Kennel Club announced French Bulldogs
are now the most popular of all
purebreds in the United States the
Frenchies Ascent knocked off the trusty
Labrador from its perch as America's Top
Dog a spot that breed held for 31 years
but the explosion and popularity of
French bulldogs has some of their
biggest fans a bit concerned
good girl for the past two years cupcake
the French bulldog has trotted the
streets of the Big Apple
Emily alone who rescued cupcake during
the pandemic was drawn to the breed
because of their manageable size and
clownish behavior she has this like
personality that's almost human
sometimes even if cupcake has cost a
loan some sleep what's your favorite
thing she does she snores really loud I
have to wear earplugs actually because
she snore so loudly
snoring aside the popularity of French
bulldogs has surged in the past decade
in 2012 Frenchies ranked 14th in
popularity on the AKC list now these
miniature mush-faced mutts I love the
Frenchie are America's top dog
step inside canine Corner a Doggy
Daycare in Brooklyn and among the
various Doodles Shepherds and retrievers
you'll nearly always find a Frenchie
when we visited we met piglet
James Aquino is an animal behaviorist
and canine Corner's co-owner in your
facility you're seeing more and more
absolutely I would say probably in the
past five years there's been an
explosion we used to see maybe three or
four a day now we'll have 10 to 15. and
everybody again because we're mentioning
the personality stuff you can't beat
this that face you can't nothing better
right there's nothing better who's
better nobody no you're the best piglet
but with the Frenchy's popularity also
come problems the rising cost to buy a
French Bulldog sometimes thousands of
dollars has made them a target for
thieves the car came and screeched in
2021 Lady Gaga's dog walker was shot and
her two French Bulldogs stolen by
suspected gang members who were
allegedly on the lookout for the breed
they also have significant health risks
most commonly associated with a
respiratory system spinal cord and hips
you'd think you'd want to be popular but
in this case no Dr Laurie Hunt is a
veterinarian who has bred French
Bulldogs for more than 20 years she's
concerned by how popular they've become
this is not necessarily cost for
celebration no it's not because you see
people seeing dollar signs that do this
is the most popular breed everybody
wants a Frenchie I'm gonna go get a dog
and a and a boy and a girl and I'm going
to have puppies and I'm going to make
myself quick money and that is the worst
thing you can do especially for a breed
like ours which really needs caretakers
hunt says anyone interested in buying a
Frenchie should look for a reputable
breeder through the American Kennel Club
or French Bulldog Club of America while
hunt cautions rescuing a French Bulldog
comes with added risks Aquino says all
dogs deserve a second chance
people unfortunately really
breed these dogs for money and there's a
lot of people or other dogs out there
that need assistance and I think my
personal preference would be to adopt
but hey if I got lucky and adopted a
Frenchie then I scored both right yeah
yeah absolutely I mean that's the case
with with cupcake right
another point from Dr Hunt if you plan
on going through a breeder recommended
by the AKC or French Bulldog Club of
America prepare to wait for a long time
but she says they are worth the wait I
mean they are so cute but they do come
with a lot of complications well I is
this PC to say I mean the the Frenchie
is just the neater version of the
Bulldog I just think of a real Bulldog
he's just always he's got drooling yeah
they're all very cute and I will also
say as the owner of a rescue dog I still
support adopting rather than shopping